My dad was a deadbeat dad,
but he was a doctor.
Specialty? Abortions.
I still made it so I guess
you're not good at your job.
Got you ****!
People will judge me. It's like,
"Why do you need a couples therapist?
You're only three months in."
Oh, just one little reason.
I'm in an interacial relationship
during a pandemic race war, that's all.
You know.
I'm heterosexual, but it's against my will.
Another dude I dated was
giving me a back massage.
He was like, "Yeah, I went kickboxing
earlier today and I fought five dudes,
I'm not even sure if I could take you."
Take me where? To an NFL scrimmage?
Are we ******* or do you want to see
me run a forty? What's going on right now?
I'm on Peacock, mother ******!